okay all right well
here we go guys breaking news on the
hogwarts legacy front we're gonna have a
full video breaking this all down later
but i wanted to get something out to you
guys quickly uh because i mean this is
major news right hogwarts legacy has
been delayed this is official
100 confirmed by avalanche on all their
social media no more rumors you can see
the screenshot here this is the image
they shared
hogwarts legacy is now scheduled to
release on friday we'll talk about that
briefly friday february 10th
2023
take a look at the platforms because we
have some other news there they do list
ps5 ps4 xbox series x xbox one steam and
the epic game store so
well first let's start with the good
news it looks like ps4 and the xbox one
folks are not going to be left behind it
looks like you will be getting the game
on that date as well the bad news if you
look at the text down there at the very
bottom the nintendo switch launch date
will be revealed soon so
i mean this this confirms that it's
going to be a different date right
otherwise they would just announce it
now
it's almost certainly going to be
releasing later is my expectation
i continue to ask guys as soon as i find
out something
i will make a post about whether or not
the switch is a cloud version or not
it's so funny anytime i talk about that
it's like completely divided some people
are so convinced that it's absolutely i
mean it's obviously the cloud version
are you kidding me and some people are
so convinced what there's a box on
amazon of course it's the physical
version
so we shall see
whether or not it's a physical version
or whether it's a cloud version
honestly like this news today actually
pushes me more toward the direction that
it is indeed a physical version because
otherwise
you know why would it need to get pushed
back if it's just a cloud version
because that i mean that that's much
more easy you don't have to build one a
completely separate version for the game
it's just you know running through the
cloud instead so the fact that the
nintendo switch version is going to
release at a different time
i think that does
indicate that it's it's very likely that
that will be kind of its own version
how it's going to run and how it's going
to perform
i don't know remains to be seen now
let's talk about this because i know a
lot of you going to be disappointed
a lot of you are going to be frustrated
and i get it trust me i do
i didn't make a full video about this
but some of you have seen me posting on
twitter and responding to some other
people and then i was on with podcast
now a couple nights ago
talking about this and
you know i i had the the video up about
quidditch and how
i am reporting that it's going to not be
playable in the game that has not been
officially confirmed um but i'm
reporting it that i've heard from people
behind the scenes
multiple sources
close to the project that it is not
going to be in the game well
one of those sources also told me
several weeks ago that this game was
highly highly highly
unlikely to make it out in 2022
so
i did make a video on it because you
know just i usually like to try and
double get that double confirmation if i
can
but i did start telling some people on
twitter and saying look guys i
i'm kind of hearing that it's it's
probably not going to make it out this
year so i've had a little more time to
prepare myself than a lot of you
probably hearing it just now for the
first time
so i have had a little more time to
prepare let's focus on the positive the
positive is they put a specific date on
it
they put an exact date on it and
my hunch is that they
i would expect that chandler would and
the marketing folks
they probably begged for this they
probably begged for like please if if
we're going to delay it please let us at
least be able to put a firm date because
can you imagine the difference today if
if this is just delayed in 2023
man i mean that would be a much
harder pill to swallow if it was just
delayed indefinitely and they put no
date on it at all other than like the
nebulous 2023 so at the very least we're
getting a specific date february 10th
2023.
now i did say i want to talk about the
fact that this is on a friday
uh so wb typically likes to release
their games on tuesdays
now i'm not going to say this confirms
but i think this is a strong indicator
that those uh early 72-hour early access
rumors are true and that that is going
to be part of the collector's edition
which would then make it so that it's
going to release on what the 7th tuesday
the 7th for folks who pre-order that
edition whatever it may be now just to
be clear this is that's pure speculation
at this point based off some things
we've found on the website that is not
confirmed yet uh and again i'm putting
this video out very shortly after this
announcement so i don't know if they
have anything else planned for the rest
of the day i'm kind of surprised that it
came just as more of a post
i thought maybe whenever they did give
the date announcement we might get
something else maybe it's going to make
an appearance at whatever playstation's
next big conference is you know there
keeps being rumors that that's gonna
happen pretty soon so you know we'll see
about that uh but the big story here is
that it's been delayed now also to try
and keep things positive for those of
you who are uh you know understandably
upset and disappointed
i don't think this is a cause for
concern and some people are gonna hate
me for saying that and and you know go
off on tangents relating to that but the
person who told me about the likelihood
of a delay also assured me that hey look
they're they're in the bug fixing phase
they're in the polishing phase they're
in the they're not adding anything else
on so i don't want people to think this
is not them delaying it because there's
something majorly wrong or they're
they're trying to add in playable
quidditch or you know
seven years and careers and
nothing like that
i do think they were they're close to
the finish line and i do think it's a
matter of getting the game in as
polished of a state as they possibly can
for that release and look i hate talking
about cyberpunk i really do guys
i really do people always want to bring
up cyberpunk anytime anything in the
video game industry happens it's like it
always connects back to cyberpunk
somehow it drives me crazy but from what
i've heard the people i've talked to and
just you know reading the tea leaves
around the industry
i think it's pretty clear that i don't
think anyone can deny that cyberpunk and
the way that game was launched
the bugs
how it was the the patches the updates
the companies they worked with that
helped them throughout that bug fixing i
mean there are lawsuits over this guys
you could look up these lawsuits that
have been filed as a result of cyberpunk
releasing in the state that it released
in
so
i think this has truly had an impact on
the industry and and the devs behind the
scenes in terms of
being extra careful even more so um then
i don't know it's hard to say normal
because
video games change so quickly like when
i was growing up it was like what was a
patch you know yes i'm dating myself
there again i know but it's like you
released the game and that was it like
you had to make sure that it was in a
good enough state to run and be a
complete game and then things as patches
started coming available you know it you
could you could make a game go gold and
then have a huge day one patch in fact
most games do still have these huge day
one patches where even major parts of
the game are are patched in
that update so
it's it's funny how the industry has
rapidly changed with those types of
things but again cyberpunk i think
really did represent a point of
things are changing again and developers
are being way more careful now which
you know yes we have to wait a little
bit longer but if this results in us
getting a more complete game a
game that runs better on day one
then i'm okay with that uh i i trust me
i i thought early december oh man i
thought that was that would have been a
perfect
release window for hogwarts legacy
december 6th that would have been a
perfect date
as i i forgot that i have those on
i'm used to those on stream but when i'm
recording this you know what we're just
gonna roll with it we're not even gonna
edit it out this is this is a pure
um what's what's the word candid video
you know normally everything's highly
edited i've got all the the footage of
the game and stuff running no this one
is just you're getting my my natural
reaction immediately after hearing this
so we'll see we'll keep our eyes on
things for the next uh the next few days
the next few weeks hopefully they do not
go dark after this i mean hopefully they
keep up with the regular updates because
i mean if they go dark again
chandler don't you guys do it don't do
it please as my voice cracks as i say
that please do not do it because then
that that is when people will really
start hitting the panic button
right now i think everyone will be you
know february 10th that's early february
it's not late into the year it's not
even late into the month of february
we were in our heads we were thinking
december anyway so i mean december
january february i mean two months two
months off of what everyone was hoping
and expecting so while i'm disappointed
we won't be able to play it this holiday
my hopes remain high guys stay positive
try and keep it positive it's okay to to
voice disagreements to voice your
concerns
feel free to do that in the comments you
you guys always do a great job um the
community we're building here is
fantastic i mean how respectful you guys
are with one another uh and you know
just try and be respectful of the folks
at avalanche as well because i'm sure a
lot of them are disappointed today this
is not the announcement they wanted to
go out uh trust me they want to be done
with the game they they want us to have
it in our hands and to be playing it but
more than anything they want it to be a
good game which is what we all want so
stay tuned for more hogwarts legacy if
you guys are not already subscribed make
sure you do that and you will stay up to
date on all the latest hogwarts legacy
news theories discussion
as always thank you all so much for
watching and i'll talk to you again soon